welcome back to the games would stage
here at e3 2016 joining two more myself
on the couch now is Pete Hines from
Bethesda hello hi how how do you think
your showcase went out we were edge of
our seat to um you know what I do at it
seems like everybody liked it but when
you're up there doing it but you just
have you have no idea i can't i can't
watch myself so i haven't gone back to
watch it to see like you can find myself
annoying so uh huh but that sounds like
you guys thought it was yeah I mean
Bethesda have like last year they pretty
much started the President Ford starting
with the showstopper like he lost it was
they turned out to be the best of of the
press conferences and this year it's
definitely up there like you opened with
quake I mean quake champions and it's
it's what people expected it to be I
know in here there was like all right
it's quick it says champions is this a
mobile there was a little worried people
were like oh god to doing him over and
then you showed off what actually was
and everyone went had a little faith
yeah ways we've been hurt before yeah
but you know I think we try and be
pretty self-aware in terms of what are
we what we're about and what what our
franchises are about and you know
Wolfenstein made a nice transition from
kind of falling off a little bit to
machine games bringing it back and
injecting a lot of life and then doom
last month has gone over really well and
folks enjoying kind of taking the legacy
of doom and it and bring it into the
modern agent and quick champions is you
know Tim being one of the co-creators of
the original quake saying look I want to
bring back all these things that people
know and remember from quakin and bring
it to to present a PC shooter I think
the most surprising thing was how
quickly it came like doom just came out
and I mean it follows Wolfenstein which
everyone really liked and it was
critically acclaimed but there was a
before Jim came out there was a lot of
talk about whether they can pull it off
whether because I could pull it off and
when it came out everyone's like oh wow
they really nailed it and that's when
the discussion of like maybe they could
do quake started happening and then you
look just came out and said yep era is
sanguine when it is when did this start
happening like when did
and was like the you had to have been
confident going into it to do it right
yeah I mean certainly certainly there
was a risk there right if it I never
felt like it would but if doom had face
planted last month well the quick
announcement is kind of awkward because
it's like you know this game that
everybody's like oh that wasn't very
good and that wasn't very fun it's kind
of hard to get everybody excited but we
were banking on what happened which is
we think dooms going to be really good
when people actually get to play it
they're gonna see what this game is
about and enjoy it and we will have
opened that door for quick champions to
step in and say and here's the you know
the next thing room and and to be able
to sort of build on that and just to
clarify like who's involved in terms of
developing the quake project because i
know for Doom you you guys did d
single-player internally and then for
yeah it was it was it single player and
then ed working with certain affinity on
multiplayer and then it working with
escalation on the snap map yeah Tom and
the folks at an escalation just did an
unbelievable job with with the snap map
stuff and making all that stuff work so
yeah this is also some folks at did
working with with another team okay that
kind of bring some of those resource
because as you said Doom was a pretty
big deal and now it is taking on a lot
of the the multiplayer aspects along
with some of the folks from battle cry
studios in Austin bringing some more
resources you know one of the things
that Marty's talked about is really
wanting to dedicate time this summer and
he talked about it some in his video to
to improving and bringing more stuff to
multiplayer to make that royalty player
experience even better and expand the
snap map as well so it's you know
there's there's a lot going on at that
studio but we're excited where it's
headed I guess that obviously doom is an
excellent game but a lot of the kind of
talk about more plays that it leaves
people a little wanting because it's not
quite consistent with the single-player
experience so there's a little there's
some fears that I've seen online that
you know the last multiplayer game that
Bethesda worked on and it worked on has
kind of like floundered a bit like
there's a worry that will let transfer
over to
to quake like is it there they're very
different they're very different things
I and and again I think it's I think
it's a fair criticism I think it and and
those guys will be the first to tell you
that they think there's a far better
version of do multiplayer than what
there is today and they are dedicated to
getting the game to that point and
that's part of our commitment to not
just DLC but free content adding new
modes adding new functionality to to get
the multiplayer there to the point where
folks are like okay this is really good
but quick champions is its own separate
set of challenges it i mean it's it's
120 hertz unlocked frame rate on a pc
it's um it's a whole different beast
yeah if you want fast vertical that
that's quake champions in it in a
nutshell so what kind of game play
experience are you going to go for
because obviously doom is its success is
based on really taking out the kind of
things that we've come to expect from
shoe isn't going back to what we
remember shoe is being in terms of quite
champions is its case of doing the same
thing and presenting a quick multiplayer
experience that's in line with what we
remember or are you planning to use like
modern you know gameplay innovation such
a no i think it's gonna be a current
take on classic quake gameplay and and
adding in this a bit more in this idea
of champions this idea of having
different characters that you can choose
and each one has a different ability
they bring but ultimately it's about
really fast gameplay the kind of arenas
and and maps that you used to in a quake
game that speed of movement super fast
twitchy controls that all of those
things you remember from quake is quake
champions quick wasn't the only surprise
d how do yo showcase this year we saw
our canes reimagining of prey yeah so
how long has that been under wraps in
its current form a long time in a while
hmm you know as Roth said look after
dishonored harvey and the team in leon
started on dishonor to and roth started
work on a new project for them something
that he wanted to he wanted to arcane
has been around for a long time you know
they're very well known for dishonored
but you guys know they've been making
stuff for for a long time and he wanted
to have that studio working on more than
one thing and had this idea of taking
the thing that they're known for which
is immersive first-person games but
bringing it to a different a different
style of game and so and they've been
working on a fur for a couple years now
at least it was a case of taking what
was what pray was paid to was before and
I know absolutely not they they throw
out from the stuff there is not a single
element of prey to in this game other
than aliens running a muck and you're
being hunted by aliens like that it pray
is distilling down literally the
franchise to that core element and then
arcane building it back up to this is
how we imagined it this is what you know
we think it is right and how would you
kind of obviously we don't want to
pigeonhole it but like what kind of how
would you characterize to get the kind
of game is a horror game is it's are
definitely not a horror game i mean it's
it's got a psychological element to it
you you see hints of some of that in in
the trailer here but it's an immersive
first person action game shooter it's a
systems-based game that arcane is known
for their known for creating really well
realized worlds that where everything
isn't just tangible but has there's
logic and reason behind it this is
there's a reason why the space station
is the way it is that you that you find
yourself on there's a there's a reason
for the ecology of the aliens that you
see and are enter fighting and trying to
survive and yeah it's it's about a lot
of player choice how are you gonna deal
with any of these situations that you're
thrown in front it's not an an
open-world game but it's that same sort
of open open level game like you see
with dishonored where you can't go
wherever you want at any given moment
but you've got a lot of freedom for sort
of what you're going to do next and how
you're gonna approach it and there's a
whole bunch of different can you
backtrack in places that you've been
before yeah it is it's um it's gonna off
a lot of replayability and a lot of
rewarding exploration because again
remember this is a game where you're
stuck on a space station and so you've
got to make do with the resources you
have and depending on the way that
you're playing there may be certain
areas that you want to go to because
there's a specific resource you need or
a specific objective you want to treat
Eve that somebody else playing a
different way doesn't care doesn't care
at all about quake cons less than two
months away can't wait for the guys to
be able to show more about what they're
what they're up to was there any
trepidation because obviously it's a
quite similar premise to alien isolation
mmm stuck on a spaceship maybe like the
psychological anger at a it's a fair
point I mean I have fundamental level
aliens on Space Station absolutely but I
think when folks see would be dead space
but yeah but I think when once folks see
what the game is really about and and
what that sort of minute to minute
gameplay looks like it they're gonna be
like yep I get it I get how all the
elements fit there's definitely there's
definitely a psychological element there
are definitely parts of the game that
scare the hell out of me but it's not a
horror game it's because of the aliens
and how they work and yeah and just
those moments of am I gonna fight here
am I going to flee here how am I gonna I
guess the thing looking at it does look
like you said it's it's you know it's
distilling prey down to its very essence
aliens on a spaceship which begs the
question why why even call a prey like
you could have put out and put this out
there as a brand new IP and we could
have son of gone to praise for doing
that but you decided to stick with pray
not pray too but like pray again and
reboot what was the thinking behind um I
don't know how I mean I don't know how
to distill down months and years of
conversation on that but ultimately it
felt like the right fit for the kind of
game that they were going to make and
and what it is they they wanted to do
okay he also revealed Skyrim special
edition mm-hmm so I mean what was the
thought process behind I mean obviously
we all love Skyrim I've put far too many
hours into that game but it's fairly
recent why why was this the one that got
the remaster and maybe not morrowind or
Oblivion sure um I mean it's fairly
recent it is five years old um but then
again dishonored was only three years
ago when it yeah
the remaster for that was more about
well it was the last new IP we released
for the last generation of consoles so
it was a it was a timeliness of you know
being able to bring it to this
generation with with Skyrim it was we
get asked about it a ton yeah a ton and
it felt like it's still a lot of work
left to do to get this onto the current
gen so there is a time factor there more
wind is two generations ago so that
would have been I mean a much more
massive undertaken and taken a
significant amount of time I mean at
that point you're probably basically we
making the game from the start yeah how
much you'd have to throw out and do all
over again you know we just felt like
skyrim is a great fit that that folks
kept asking about it that the amount of
content there from a mod standpoint in
the PC community and what those modders
would then be able to bring over to the
console folks um felt like a good fit so
look at I mean I played a ton of Skyrim
at home and I can't wait to play this
yeah when it comes out even though I've
been playing it forever since you know
yeah well before before launch I'm
gettin itchy itchy fingers again like
watching that hates me yeah i still like
hearing it so but that's also revealed
bethesda vr so you guys are pretty much
one of the big publishers to make a real
big push into VR a real commitment so
you've had the doom experience that's
not gonna be transferred into the full
game yeah um playing a game at 60 frames
a second leg baby it's a it's a vomit
comment like it is literally just put
the bucket next to the headset and wait
about 10 seconds so it needs to be a
different kind of of gaming a different
kind of experience what we've got today
is sort of during the show is an idea a
direction some thoughts around what that
might be and showing off some of the
tech and what it looks like whereas
fallout is just the game it's fallout 4
I mean it's VR controls
still I mean it's not coming out till
next year so there's still a lot of work
and thinking around how that's going to
work but it's a first look at what a
full fallout 4 game would look like on a
VR it's not for me the demo on the show
floor the moment is um you don't you
don't necessarily walk around so much
you teleport between yeah in in this
build you're not walking place to place
your sort of figuring out where you want
to go to next but that's part of
figuring out how how that looks when the
game ships I I genuinely have no idea
okay so just the on the HTC vive or are
they talk right now we're just we're
just announced for the HTC vive whether
we would do this for anything else any
other platform all things are possible
but right now it's just for the HTC vive
next year cool um another quick one we
only have less than a minute left but
fallout dlc this is gonna be is it
you've announced 333 today so we're in
beta testing this week on contraptions
that'll be out next week so that adds a
bunch of new gadgets and gizmos to add
to the workshop next month is build your
own vault okay and recruit vault
dwellers and run experiments on them and
all that stuff and then august is nucca
world a bigger bigger area at the
faction to the game like a dystopian
disneyland yeah yeah very dystopian um
but it will be talking about that
probably a little bit further down the
road but kind of excited for what that
brings from a gameplay standpoint and
then PS 4 mods still planning on coming
out this month so they're out on Xbox
one we're almost done with the work we
need to do on ps4 so that'll bring a
bunch new content from from all the
great mod creators to play on ps4 was
there a vast difference in bringing like
different challenges yeah bringing yes
like every single platform has different
ways of handling all of these things and
when you're talking about bringing
something created on the pc and having
at work on a console and all the sort of
rules for how it behaves and what do you
do if they just rip the Lord of the
Rings assets and drop them in there and
be all of that stuff has to be managed
and figured out what I'll be able to get
much more n DS of it everybody asked
that I think I'm gonna have to
personally reach out please do send an
email to those folks and say can we
please have permission for this mater to
put up this thing because it's I think
the number one to be in there yeah
request that and Thomas the thing I was
going to say that's number two yep Makka
man and Thomas the Tank Engine after e3
those would be the first two emails I
have the power yes I will make that
happen thank you so much for joining us
when is quite conce we can find out more
details but firstly first of August
Dallas Texas we're gonna have we're
going to be showing new info on quake
champions we're gonna have new info on
prey probably more info on upcoming doom
dlc nuclear world I'm sure we'll be
talking about more there so definitely
we need to get you guys down to Texas
yeah look like someone's yeah I'd
assorted all right thank you so much
guys for more coverage from this year's
e3 make sure you stay tuned of caustic
gamespot com you're watching the game
spot stage brought to you by airheads